んうん
ええええ
tan
楽にしてていいんだよ逆にするか楽にしている匠を輝かせるのが俺だしてことだから
うん
しなかった性ってるねこんにちははじめ社長です
a 今よってバー
はいというわけでこのよっている状態で僕って誰がいたって遅いと思うんですよ基本的
に普段の僕より何倍もテンションがおかしいっていうかね
前も一回やったと思うんですけども斎藤さんってやつをねちょっとやっていきたいと
思います朝伊藤さどんなアプリかというとまあ基本的にあるですねっもうなんかアボ
ロンみたいなコーナーしれないとね
大会はをするっていうアプリなんでこの今の僕なら目標としたら僕ってバレねーんじゃ
ねーか暗いときも積めばいるんで今なら何か何でも話せるんだと思って会話も弾むのか
なと思ってちょっとちょっと今からちょっと待ったらちょっと
会でちょっとゴリゴリやってるんですけども斎藤されていこうと思います
出会いが楽しみながらフォレス庁舎さんとお話できちゃう
嬉しいな
[音楽]
ん
もし麻酔
[音楽]
もしもしー
はわわうざくんなよわっ
パリあるもしもしいってえっ
[音楽]
見て
俺の返っ
俺のお前のだよ俺はお前だ俺のか
俺のことが好きなのかん
[音楽]
el ん
もしも粋粋がるえっ膀胱に決め
まあこんにちはあはいおいくつですか
北24
you to bar ですはい
なる佐藤だか肇社長です
[音楽]
ん
今ですねー
酔った勢いで斉藤さんをやってるんですよ
いやー
四日市おいでバッハ
jian
怖いですかあっ
あっっ
[音楽]
あーもしもし
ブレア
申します
死んだああ
野手メって言ったのは青てっちゃダメなんだぞ
[音楽]
今日も1日
いいことがあるといいね駄目だろ
[音楽]
はい帰れはいっ
スジ見せちゃ寝てますね
られてしまったようだなあっ幅れたぞ
着任バレるよ
[音楽]
聴こえてますかはい
今日は8月の15日
今日も元気で明るく楽しいしようっ
[音楽]
4いろんな人がいるね
もう調子こんにちははいこんにちはエー
今じゃこちら著
アメリカとん
えっなんでも買ったっちゃったので嘘んなわかる
バレリスたかやんでそんなわかる
[音楽]
船に入ったカーンパニックアイカーンでぃんぐろーはんにゃあっ
なーーんとって
あってキャピってる僕も元ないん
ろびことわからんだいいいいいいぽぽ二種で2倍
日本キャンパリー
vipper
ええええ
yeah
[音楽]
あろんあ my name ビーズ大輔
えっ
[音楽]
あーもしもしうん天罰が下れが良い
えっ0
エロってのはちゅあねー
しみシミズ
ran 何 money with マイケルジャクソ
えええええええ
いやいやいやいや
ann japanese バーバリーブルーああ
no やや
大劇 j
バルフ
[音楽]
ん写真
文字ます
負けが待つがいたとかあるのかいっ
来ますが入ったのところ抹茶言ったってどういうことだ
[音楽]
こんばんは
はいこんばんはー
あなたを闇の世界へ誘うものダーク操作等
誰ダーク操作だな
ダンク層からそうだ成田のあなたを闇へ誘うことそれが私
ラグそうならそうなそれね
今からあなたを闇へいざな参ったか
参った参ったか
参った参ったはいああそうだろう
あっはああ
ああああああ
ああ
アガラナーン効かないよ
ん
[音楽]
パターン my name is ストーリー re re re re good
選挙ベルな家
ウォッチをネームバージョン name by ねぇウェイ
所ぴょん青ベリングリーン
good 目 on air
ブービー e 4 al are you do
[音楽]
うーん
ぶううううううっ
ねえ飯うーん
あああああ
をバーン
またお願いしてい1 j
[音楽]
モッツアレラチーズ
ん
交通あれが記述
モッツアレラチーズ
おっ誰だしん
恐れ
[音楽]
んまっラベラっちいー
me
ああああああ
はぁ
tan
me
はぁ
せないんああ
ああああああああ
あああああった
蒼龍がーうわぁ
おおーー
ああああああああわー
[音楽]
モッツアレラチーズ
ています
グルーチーズん
レアチーズ
[拍手]
俺県縮景分
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
マイターヤッターん
ni
me
dea
あっはぁ